medio oriente y el magreb conforman la
región más riesgosa del mundo para
ejercer el periodismo así se desprende
de la clasificación que reveló
reporteros sin fronteras en el día
mundial de la libertad de prensa si nos
fijamos en los últimos 20 puestos de su
ranking de 180 países y territorios 9
corresponden a esta zona que en un 52%
de su geografía tiene escenarios muy
graves para quienes informan si bien
siria irak e irán son los últimos de la
tabla regional kuwait es el país que más
descendió con un retroceso de 53
posiciones entre esas caídas la
organización destaca la presión política
en líbano donde los profesionales de los
medios sufren exilio ataques y amenazas
de muerte que a veces se materializan
como el asesinato del periodista lockman
slim crítico de hezbollah mientras en
internet las persecuciones se
intensifican sobre territorios como el
palestino las violencias físicas
aumentan debido en gran parte a los
bombardeos israelíes de mayo pasado en
gaza que causaron la muerte a dos
periodistas palestina bajo 38 puestos de
ese ranking desde 2018 reporteros las
contabilizan más de 140 violaciones
israelíes contra periodistas palestinos
que cubren las protestas semanales a su
vez medios palestinos denuncia en 78
agresiones israelíes a periodistas
palestinos sólo en abril con arabia
saudita y egipto con las peores cárceles
para los informadores y ante los
arrestos guerras y violencias en esta
región la organización augura un camino
largo para llegar a la libertad de
prensa plena en medio oriente y el
magreb